hey guys is Dennis the founder think
here and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of this series premiere of
Fargo on FX basically is based on on the
movie right which is based on true
events supposedly yeah this is like
first ups was called a crocodile dilemma
it's it's this is loose that they went
to the Cohens I want the Cohens last I
think to actually ask permission for
this and it's not it's like everything's
one of those another critic who said
it's like everything's tweaked five
degrees it's not the same story but some
stuff you'll watch and if you've seen
the movie recently like I don't know the
movies is old now and older so I got
96-90 something I say and you'll watch
like oh let's drop it from the movie
though things are like oh that's
different so you have the Nygaard played
by Martin Freeman which is weird hearing
him with that axe his is the most I
think because he's British his is the
most over-the-top accent I mean it's
good but he's he's really playing it up
I mean he's the good he is the guy from
Sheamus i can remember william h mean
he's kind of the william h macy
character and then of course you have
Molly who's kind of played by this
unknown actors who just does a really
good job who is the franchise mcdermott
care that one her i believe an academy
award for her role she did a great job
in that but it's just tweaked it's not
exactly the same but it's tweaked and of
course i think for me besides the
character of molly i think Billy Bob
Thornton here is just awesome I think
Billy Bob kind of forget about him and I
think every now and then maybe every
five six years you'll watch something
you'd be like oh yeah he can act I
forgot Billy Bob can act like he's a
good actor I thought he was he was
subtle on this kind of low-key but he
did a really good job i love the i'm
gonna say the atmosphere the way it's
set up its kind of fun it's like just
being in the world of Fargo but it's a
different story but you're still in that
environment that kind of dark Coen
brothers comedy which I know you're not
always a fan of so it's courage to see
what you thought of this yeah it's I'm
still I liked I liked the episode I
thought it was solid I'm not raving
about it like other people at the same
time like you said like I I'm not a coen
brothers fan that doesn't mean I don't
like their movies I do like their movies
I think they're they're wonderful
directors it's just the stories i think
in characters they choose to tell don't
really appeal to me right
and so I'm gonna wait and see some more
episodes I may end up like in this
series more than the movie but but
coming from me that's not saying that
much Billy Bob is definitely the main
reason why i like this this episode of
the show and i had i am gonna continue
to watch because i liked his performance
i liked his character and i think right
you know i think he's gonna be able to
play off with martin freeman's character
Lester Nygaard very well I like this
again don't know her but Molly leave the
extras name is Alison Tomlin I leaves
how you say it she was great I think
she's not French simic dermot she's not
pregnant and your friends McDermott is
pregnant very very pregnant and in that
movie and she's not they kind of give
that pregnancy to the other police
officer his wife what one that died yeah
I want to die yeah and I thought she did
a great job she's not quite as goofy
like she's kind of serious already it's
not so eager to younger too so I mean
they're kind of they're using some of
the Coen brothers stuff with a change in
a little bit it's not the exact same
thing as a coen brothers adaptation
which is great we're going to spend 10
hours in this world the Premier's an
hour and a half this is going to be 10
episodes just in miniseries they throw a
lot at you in the first episode I mean
we also get to see a little bit of colin
hanks who you know i like Colin hazy
serviceable he pops up every time they
go there tom hanks kid you know he kind
of pops up he's you know charming guy
he's fine you know it has a daughter and
I love that running with him oh yeah
well my favorite is so good ever seen
he's like you know you want to go home
be with your daughter just just just go
away like you're somehow you'll think
back yeah you'll remember that this is
you know basically saying this is the
time that you were gonna die right yeah
you didn't cuz you made the right choice
by going away I don't know what Billy
Bob was doing though racing around after
you know committing right or the right
yeah like what why are you doing that
first of all you're pretty you know I
don't know how far that other town is
but you're away no one's really chasing
you yeah but I don't know why you're
driving like that hello to Billy Bob
when he was talking to you know martin
freeman's character like on the phone in
my room was panicking he's like my wife
she's she's in the basement she's in
like he doesn't know what to say and
he's just like have you been a bad boy
he just comes back it's so good it's
it's just got that humor and but it's
dark you know it's got the drama's got
some action
and I just love the world it's really
cool yeah I really like Billy Bob and
you know what you know you and me are
big justified fans yeah Billy Bob
actually and obviously he came first on
the scene yeah well he came first but he
kind of has like that Timothy all in fun
it'll to justify it was kind of that you
know kind of smooth talking kind of like
you know he's he's tough but he kind of
you know present you know place it off I
don't know I get that kind of vibe from
a because it's on FX as well but all
right I really like that and he's
definitely the main reason watching I
think also martin freeman's character a
lesser Nygaard it's funny because it's
like he's a man who's you know being
constantly pushed by other people by you
know the saying that he's not a man his
wife the bully and these are the people
who end up dying yeah no one respects
him who's still around his brother
doesn't respect him he dropped that big
machine gun yeah and he's just like look
or you know you're my older brother I'm
so look up to right you know and he's
just kind of a klutz a clumsy even him
you know X killing his wife was just so
clumsily done right and then yeah Billy
Bob kind of egging him on trying to like
empower him be like you know some guy
said that to me did it to me out I'd
kill him you know like that whole just
matter of fact you know I mean it's
gonna be a fun combination with those
who know I like to is that the cops you
know they had the Minnesota accent like
oh you know all that kind of stuff but
they're not stupid like the cop that was
killed he's not dumb you know he kind of
is doing obviously molly is very
intelligent she was like tracking and
looking and at the hospital like looking
at records and asking questions like in
this small town don't get a lot of major
crimes like this but the cops aren't
stupid they're not just not all but not
gonna be like just made fun of the whole
time that's interesting too and you know
it's very sad but effective scene is
when she shows up at the dead cops house
with the wife enjoy holding the paint
knows that he had bought it's like
screwed you knew immediately she knew
immediately what happened right another
character that I hope to see more if he
wasn't it that much is the diner owner
or got ya do ya he played by Keith
Carradine
was wild bill hickok in Deadwood yeah so
I'm hoping to see more of him because I
really like him as an actor yeah yeah I
think it was a solid start I'm looking
forward to it i just it was it did start
off kind of slow for me nor episode but
you know but then it started moving
along I mean it's good i mean FX is i
mean they're they're changing the game a
little bit in terms of basic cable i
should say there are many HP item yeah
in that i'm sure you've heard the some
of the articles like the president's
very outspoken they they they bid for
true detective they didn't get it you
know hpo outbid them and the post HBO
can do a little bit more but FX they
push the boundaries and meet watch sons
of anarchy they in the Americans they
push it about as far as they can go i
know because i used to watch the shield
yeah yeah yeah you know they they show
the butts they like a morir like we can
show that we can show the front which
will show side boob but they they do a
good job they have like the guillermo
del toro's they are the strain come in
the other show coming out this summer
they they're really definitely a
miniseries are working with i believe
maybe Paul Giamatti's and then really
they got a lot of stuff on the table sir
great yeah they're right second favorite
network yes HBO yeah they do a much
better job in my opinion AMC yeah MC has
mad men and breaking bad with your great
shows but like with turn Walking Dead
sometimes falters I feel like FX is a
lot more consistent yeah definitely
alright guys so that's what we thought
of the premiere episode of Fargo what do
you guys think let us know on our
website pikir calm and or on our YouTube
channel think Carol pro make sure to
subscribe to that it wasn't find us on
twitter uh Dennis I already got a lot of
your you no questions asked us if we
were watching the show you know
crocodile dilemma the open show it's
coming on this week let us know what you
thought of the next episode and yeah I'm
sure maybe we'll teen tune in again
towards the finale or something see how
it all wraps up and what we think so as
always you can find us at think hero i'm
at griffin de and we also a facebook
page that's facebook.com slash think
your fans make sure you like that page
and share our videos on Twitter and
Facebook and all that stuff
you